kids that spend 2 hours or more out ofd
doors per day have a far lower incidence
of myopia nearsightedness and even if
they're on iPads and books and computers
there's something about viewing things
further than 3 or 4 feet away from us
for a significant portion of our day
doesn't mean you have to be staring off
into the Horizon but as opposed to near
viewing where you're looking at
something within about 4 feet of oneself
watch people's behavior look at how they
go through the day they're spending most
of their time looking at things about a
foot to a foot and a half away and as a
consequence the eyeball gets longer this
is a wellestablished fact in animal
models and humans and then the visual
image isn't focused onto the retina the
light sensing portion at the back of the
eye the image Falls in front of the
retina so-called near sidedness it's
falling too near to the lens fortunately
that the eyeball actually can change in
length so viewing things further away
can actually especially early in life
allow the eyeball to adjust it shape and
so the point is we need to get out and
view things at a distance